good morning John it's Friday and I'm
just gonna go ahead and admit this even
though I've talked a lot about it I'm
pretty sure I don't know what burnout is
I thought I did I thought that it was
just when you worked and you worked and
you worked and you didn't pay any
attention to yourself until finally your
mind or your body just collapse and okay
that is a kind of burnout but I've also
seen and experienced burnout where I
continued to work through the burnout
I've been burned out on one part of my
life
but not another and I'm like is this
distress I know the feeling I'm feeling
they call it burnout is that what
everybody else means a really good
conversation this morning with Marc
Luber and which we talked a lot about
the neurotransmitters responsible for
making us feel like our lives are
rewarding and how they and the things
that trigger that release are ultimately
responsible for us doing anything and
then he said this to me
burnout is when the treadmill keeps
going but the dopamine runs out so you
just keep running even though it doesn't
feel good anymore that is another kind
of burnout and that made me think a
thing so let's start with this to get
anything done you need fuel and you need
the opportunity to burn it you can have
a lot of gasoline and you're not going
anywhere unless you have a car so what's
the fuel a thousand different things the
desire for status for an easier life for
joy for a feeling of being useful to not
disappoint your parents to see something
new on Twitter to destroy your enemies
to feed your children whether these are
real or perceived things their fuel and
whether they're good fuel or bad fuel
their fuel all of them make you want
stuff and then when you get it you feel
good at least temporarily and then
there's the opportunity to burn the fuel
that can be a bunch of different things
to freetime skills education resources
job history health confidence drive
looking the part speaking the language
both literally and metaphorically if
we're feeling a burnout cuz I don't
think there is any one burnout you got
to look at your fuel and you got a look
at your opportunities are you ignoring
your own needs or are you driving
without any pay off are you working to
exhaustion or have you lost a feeling of
meaning in your work those are all super
different things but I've heard them all
described as burnout some people have
the fuel and no opportunity other people
have the opportunity and their fuel has
just run out my greatest moments of
burnout were when I still had the fuel I
just ran
of moments in the day cuz one too many
things went wrong I had the fuel I just
didn't have any more car to put it into
but oftentimes in creative industries
I've seen the exact opposite who are
once legitimately joyful in their work
losing the fuel because our brains
aren't designed to get amped the same
way by the same input over and over
again like the first time you get a
million view video that's gonna drive
you for a long time and the 20th time
you get a million view video just
doesn't feel as good so you're stuck
with the same amount of work the same
amount of expectation from your audience
for a lot less reward we are more than
machines and what triggers the dopamine
release is to some extent influenced by
our values and by our worldview and
those are things that we can change
intentionally about ourselves if we
don't diversify what fuels us we need
more and more of that input to fuel the
same amount of work and if we start to
believe that loving each other and
taking care of each other and taking
care of ourselves isn't valuable it
won't be I think that's some of why we
end up paying money for bath bombs and
yoga classes because it's a way to
assign economic value to taking care of
ourselves
it helps us actually believe that this
is worth it and it shouldn't be that
hard and it's why we have holidays to
remind ourselves to be thankful for
other people in our lives remembering
that there are people who are important
in our lives
reminds us that we are all so important
regardless of the efficiency of our
economic output I don't think this
conversation is done can't be handled in
a four-minute video obviously I read
several things this week that you might
have also read I've linked to those in
the description I think this
conversation is important and I hope
that it continues in the comments John
I'll see you on Tuesday